>> BIDEN MISS HANDLED MORE
PAPERS AND IT'S GIVEN DEMOCRATS
THE VAPORS.
SO COULD DOCUMENTS BE THE LAST
STRAW FOR AMERICA'S SENILE
GRANDPA?
FOLLOWING THE WHITE HOUSE
ADMISSION THAT MORE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND AT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S DELAWARE HOME,
IT SEEMS EVEN FELLOW DEMS ADMIT
IT'S WORTH A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION, RIGHT?
AND THAT INCLUDES ADAM SCHIFF, A
GUY NORMALLY LESS INTERESTED IN
THE TRUTH THAN MADONNA'S PLASTIC
SURGEON.
SO DOES HE THINK APPOINTING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL WAS THE RIGHT
MOVE?
>> I DO THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
MOVE.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE THAT NATIONAL
SECURITY WAS JEOPARDIZED?
>> I DON'T THINK WE CAN EXCLUDE
THE POSSIBILITY WITHOUT KNOWING
MORE OF THE FACTS.
WE HAVE ASKED FOR AN ASSESSMENT.
I THINK WE OUGHT TO GET THE SAME
ASSESSMENT TO THE DOUBTS AS AT
THE MAR LARGO DOCUMENTS.
>> GREG: HOLY CRAP.
DID OUR LEAST FAVORITE MARTIAN
SAY BIDEN SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE
TRUMP?
WOULD THAT MAKE HUNTER JEALOUS.
NOW PEOPLE ARE TURNING ON JOE.
>> CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS ARE TO
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY AND THEY ARE
TO BE HANDLED WITH A GREAT DEAL
OF CARE.
NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> BY STUMBLING AND BUMBLING
AROUND, BY NOT GETTING THE
TIMELINE RIGHT, UNKNOWN NUMBER
OF DOCUMENTS FOUND IN BIDEN --
NO, NO MORE UNKNOWN.
AMATEUR HOUR IS OVER AND THEY
JUST MISHANDLED IT FROM DAY ONE,
BECAUSE AGAIN, I'M ONLY SAYING
IT BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
>> GREG: ONLY SAYING IT BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE, EXCELLENT REASONING.
BEAVIS.
I KEEP SWITCHING THEM UP.
MORNING JOE SHOULD SPRING FOR
SOME NAME TAGS.
FINALLY, JIM ACOSTA ACCUSING THE
REPUBLICANS OF DOING EXACTLY
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
DOING SINCE THE BIG BANG.
>> THE ARGUMENT SEEMS TO BE
BIDEN IS BOTH NOT MENTALLY FIT
TO HOLD OFFICE AND YET HE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE THIS, IN THE
MINDS OF SOME REPUBLICANS, THIS
CRIMINAL MASTERMIND WHO IS
HOLDING ON TO THESE DOCUMENTS
FOR SOME NEFARIOUS REASON.
DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE?
>> GREG: YOU USED TO SAY THE
SAME DAMN THING ABOUT TRUMP, YOU
JACK ASS.
FUN FACTS.
[APPLAUSE]
FUN FACT, DID YOU JUST SAY
KAYLEIGH McENANY TO JIM, HE WETS
HIMSELF.
WHAT DOES JOE THINK OF ALL THIS?
>> NO, YOU CAN'T COMMIT A CRIME
IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTING A CRIME.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW -- I KNOW
THERE IS A BOX IN MY GARAGE BUT
I KEEP MY GARAGE LOCKED.
AND I WOULDN'T EVEN KNOW HOW --
THERE IS A BUTTON.
YOU PUSH A BUTTON BUT THE BUTTON
IS IN THE CAR AND THE CAR IS IN
THE GARAGE SO HOW IS ANYONE
GOING TO GET IN THERE?
COME ON, MAN.
NO, IT'S MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY,
SO COULD YOU PLEASE LET ME GET
BACK TO CALLING EVERYONE WHO
DOESN'T AGREE WITH ME A RACIST.
THANK YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: CHARLIE -- I'M SORRY,
WHEN ADAM SCHIFF CHANGES HIS
TUNE, THAT FAST, SOMETHING IS
UP.
I SMELL SOMETHING.
>> YES.
>> GREG: WHAT DO I SMELL,
CHARLIE?
>> I DON'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE FOR
THIS BUT THIS IS MY THEORY SINCE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
LET'S GO WITH IT.
THE F.B.I. IS ALREADY
INVESTIGATING HUNTER BIDEN.
AT SOME POINT, IMAGINE THE
STUFF, YOU KNOW, THINK ABOUT ALL
THE STUFF WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
ABOUT.
COULD YOU IMAGINE IF YOU HAD
LIKE SEARCH WARRANTS, AND YOU
HAD INVESTIGATIVE POWERS.
IMAGINE THE STUFF THE F.B.I. IS
PROBABLY DIGGING UP ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN NOW.
WALL OF HIS CONNECTIONS.
I REALLY BELIEVE AT SOME POINT
AND IT'S HAPPENED IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS, SINCE THE
ELECTION, THEY ALL GOT TOGETHER,
AND WE NOW KNOW HOW DEEPLY
INVESTED THE INTEL COMMUNITY IS,
IN OUR POLITICS, THEY LOOKED AT
ONE ANOTHER AND SAID, MAN, THIS
IS NOT GOOD.
WE CAN'T --
>> GREG: GET HIM OUT.
>> WE CAN'T STICK UP FOR THIS
GUY.
WE CAN'T COVER FOR THIS GUY IN
THE NEXT ELECTION LIKE WE DID IN
THE LAST ELECTION.
AND, I MEAN, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
RATS JUMPING SHIP LIKE THIS.
>> GREG: THIS IS CRAZY, CAT.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE TREATED
LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S NOT.
ARE THE WALLS CLOSING IN?
>> I'M GOING TO TRY TO PUT THIS
LIKE GENTLY AND KINDLY, WHICH IS
SOMETIMES TOUGH FOR ME.
I JUST DON'T -- OF COURSE, THEY
WOULD BE DOING THIS BECAUSE WHY
ARE THEY GOING TO GO OUT OF
THEIR WAY TO PROTECT JOE BIDEN,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
WORRIED, OH, THIS IS SUCH A
SHAME THAT THIS IS HAPPENING,
IT'S GOING TO CUT SHORT WHAT
WOULD BE A LONG, PROMISING
POLITICAL CAREER?
HE'S BEEN IN POLL SIX JUST ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN A
COUNTRY.
>> RIGHT.
>> I DID MATH, TOO.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A FACT.
SO, I MEAN, REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY DECIDE TO HITCH
THEMSELVES TO THIS WAGON OR NOT,
WAGON IS NOT GOING MUCH FURTHER.
SO I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE
EASIEST THINGS IN THE WORLD FOR
THEM TO DO, TO SAY, YES, THIS IS
BAD, BECAUSE, I MEAN, HE'S
REALLY OLD.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE UP TO THE
TASK OF BEING PRESIDENT, NOR HAS
HE BEEN THE ENTIRE TIME.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I DON'T KNOW, IT'S THE
OPPOSITE OF JUMPING ON A
BANDWAGON.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THIS IS TERRIBLE, BECAUSE THERE
IS NO GOOD THAT CAN COME FROM
STAYING BY HIS SIDE.
>> GREG: I USED THIS ANALOGY
BEFORE, JOEY, ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE POPULAR KID IN SCHOOL HAS
DONE SOMETHING REALLY
EMBARRASSING, AND EVERYBODY JUST
LETS HIM SUFFER ALONE.
IN ISOLATION.
>> I GOT PUNCHED IN THE FACE BY
A GIRL IN THE BLEACHERS ONE TIME
AND I WAS NOT POPULAR FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AFTER THAT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I MIGHT NOT
HAVE EVER BEEN POPULAR TO BEGIN
WITH.
I DON'T REMEMBER.
BLOCKED THAT PART OUT.
LISTEN, JIM ACOSTA, NOBODY
THINKS THIS DUDE IS A CRIMINAL
MASTERMIND.
WE THINK HE'S AN IDIOT.
SO MUCH OF AN IDIOT THAT HE
TAKES CARE OF HIS CRACK HEAD
SON.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, HE'S
ADMITTED -- [ BLEEP ] -- HE
STOOD IN FRONT OF US AND TOLD US
HE MADE A DEAL WITH A UKRAINIAN
TO GET AN INVESTIGATOR OUT OF
OFFICE.
WE'RE ALL JUST SITTING HERE
TWIRLING OUR THUMBS IN AMACE.
THAT PEOPLE LIKE JIM ACOSTA JUST
DON'T CARE BECAUSE ANYTHING IS
BETTER THAN TRUMP IN THEIR
RELIGION AND THEY ARE COMING,
YOU KNOW, AS MY MAMMA WOULD SAY,
JESUS IS COMING BACK, LIKE IT'S
RECKONING.
IT'S TIME TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORSHIPPING THIS
WHOLE TIME.
>> GREG: MARTHA, JESUS IS COMING
BACK.
>> WHAT I TAKE AWAY FROM THIS
TURN OF EVENTS THAT YOU GUYS ARE
ALL TALKING ABOUT IS, THIS MIGHT
BE REALLY BAD IF WE NEED IT TO
BE.
SO, WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS,
YOU KNOW, ALL THE SUPPORTERS OF
THE PRESIDENT, AND WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THIS ON THE BURNER
BECAUSE IF WE NEED THIS, WE'RE
GOING TO EMPLOY THIS EXIT
STRATEGY, RIGHT?
SO THEY ARE HAPPY BECAUSE NOW
THEY HAVE AN EXIT STRATEGY, AND
YOU CAN KIND OF TRACE THE UPS
AND DOWNS OF THE BIDEN
FAVORABILITY, RIGHT?
BECAUSE BEFORE HE RAN, OR WHEN
HE WAS RUNNING, THEY LIKED
EVERYBODY BUT HIM.
DAVID AXELROD CAME OUT AND SAID
HE WAS MR. McGOO WONDERING
AROUND THE STAGE.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHERE HE IS AND
HE SHOULDN'T BE DOING THIS.
SOMETHING TO THAT EFFECT.
THEN AFTER THE MIDTERMS HE'S
LIKE SUPERMAN, RIGHT?
AND NOW, ALL OF A SUDDEN HE'S
GOING TO RUN AGAIN.
AFTER EVERYONE SAID THERE IS NO
WAY HE'S GOING TO RUN AGAIN.
SO NOW, ALL THE WAY DOWN, RIGHT?
SO I THINK WE HAVE A FEW MORE OF
THESE CYCLES TO GO BEFORE 2024
BUT AS YOU WERE SAYING, WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS AT THE BREAK,
IF THEY DON'T HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE
TO BE THEIR 2024 CANDIDATE, THEY
PROBABLY WILL FIND A WAY TO
RALLY BACK AROUND TO JOE IF THEY
THINK HE'S THE ONLY ONE WHO CAN
DO IT.
>> GREG: JUST GOT TO PUMP HIM
FULL OF DRUGS.
>> IT WORKS.
HIS PERFORMANCE THE DAY AFTER
THE ELECTION WAS ONE OF THE
GREAT WONDERS